let's talk about the patriarchy let's
see this is from her
perspective
wow
perspective remember when they wanted to
change history to her story because
history was like had his in it and as oh
you remember those classes those gender
studies classes in college where they
were like all language is intrinsically
male
so we have to create a new language for
women okay you see where i'm going with
this all right so we're going to start
i'm going to do some live reacts so
tyler unfortunately is going to have to
pause i know you love that tyler um so
let's pull it up and let's get started
and see what she has to say
here she is she has a lot of critically
such a gender-based trauma and i have
two relevant degrees from harvard on
this let's talk about men who say not
all men this behavior comes from three
sources first this is a male pikmi
behavior oh i understand there are men
out there who are acting in abusive ways
but i'm not one of them i'm one of the
good guys that's a total delusion by the
way in a patriarchy everyone has
internalized misogyny sexism and
impressive already i can't man first of
all she has two degrees she needs you to
know that
not one but she has two degrees
uh gender studies i'm guessing this
reads like a gender studies professor
you know she's got the whole look going
on you know you're a dude you walk into
that classroom to take that class you're
like oh [ __ ] man i'm gonna try no matter
what i say i'm i'm screwed you know i'm
mansplaining when i'm not i'm gonna be
told to sit back i'm gonna have to hear
about the patriarchy 24 hours a day
seven days a week you just you know what
drop that class guys i'm telling you man
you can't win
anyway
she has the two degrees so we have to
listen she starts off though already
with that nonsense about how
because we're in a patriarchy which i
would question are we are we though in
2022 do you really think we're a
patriarchy
think about it because of that everyone
has this intrinsic misogyny okay i
cannot stand
when people do this when it's like you
cease to be an individual
you cease to have your own character
like be responsible for your own actions
no no no it's that because you grew up
in the united states and we're a
patriarchy you are a misogynist even if
you don't act like one underneath it all
in your subconscious you're a massage
and they do this with race right they
say well because this was once a country
that had slavery and it's bred into your
upbringing generations and generations
back you are a closet bracelet you don't
know it but you are a closet racist how
disgusting to say that to people why not
here's an idea for the feminist i have a
fancy degree too i just don't put it up
here i don't have my master of arts
slammed up here you know why because i
learned more working in a cocktail
lounge using practical skills and
learning people skills than i ever
learned at columbia university from my
dumb masters that's the honest truth so
you like your degree whatever but how
about we start looking at people as
people
how about there are legitimate people
who are racist out there and they show
you with their words and actions you
don't assume somebody else is racist
just because once in the united states
there was slavery
no that's not a reflection of their
behavior you don't assume
that a man is a misogynist
just because there's this patriarchy
that is woven through the system how do
you know how that man was raised how do
you know what his values are how do you
know how he treats his friends how do
you know how he treats his girlfriend
how do you know how he treats his sister
you don't know anything about him
don't assume that that guy is a bad
person just because it fits your history
book talking point that revisionist
history that you probably read as bible
all right let's continue tyler
to treat women that's why we all gotta
unlearn patriarchal ways of behaving
number two the need to control women's
voices notice how they are tone policing
women far more than they are mad at
those men who are abusing harassing and
raping women who are giving rest of the
men a bad name number three male
superiority complex this would relate to
the male pygmy behavior oh i understand
there will be awful men out there like
who will abuse and rape and harass you
and oppress you but i'm not one of them
if you depend on me to protect you from
male violence you'll be good that
instills in women a fear of it's wrong
what is wrong with somebody saying like
hey
i have no problem with a guy saying to
me if i'm if i'm out there and i'm
sharing my story like say i say to a guy
like hey i had a bad experience with
another dude and this is what happened
like say i share it right and we're
talking and he says
that guy's shitty that sounds awful i'm
not like that what's wrong with
distinguishing yourself first of all
that that means you're acknowledging
there are people who act shitty you're
saying yeah that's not cool i don't
support that kind of behavior that's not
me
no she has a problem with that because
she needs you to believe that you're
also a misogynist and that you're also
capable of horrible things because
you're patriarchy secondly what the hell
is tone policing
what is this [ __ ] that they tone
police now
nobody polices my tone i don't know if
you know lady but this whole room is
filled with guys right now tyler doesn't
come in here before the show and say
you really gotta watch your tone no
that's not what's happening
what are you even what is she talking
about do you know what terrible thing is
that i think you'd walk over and smack
me
you know tyler you're
giving me a bad reputation now
but what does that mean tone that means
that that women are told that they're
too emotional is that what that is what
she's talking about telling somebody to
calm down is that what she like i i
don't know i have no idea i have no idea
what she's talking about i'm going to be
honest with you neither does she she
just read that in some books some she
went to a seminar and they said don't
allow me to tone police you and she was
like oh that's sense
tone policing
that's what happened there well and for
your daily dose of irony she's talking
about the patriarchy right she's
graduating college with two degrees yeah
okay
right what do you think she would have
to say about leah thomas what do you
think she'd have to say about
transgender men who shower with women
what do you think that she'd have to say
about the man who goes into the women's
spa and shows off his junk
no they don't no no no then you ha again
then you have to bow down to the woke
cause of the moment and suddenly all
this stuff about feminism and women's
rights and i'm sure she's like a big
person on equality i don't know what she
defines as equality i'm sure she's got
plenty to say about the pay gap we
talked about that myth the other day
it's just nauseating to me and you guys
know i don't like generalizations i
don't like men do this women do that
because there's too many people that
don't fit in the box i cannot stand
someone who calls himself a feminist
comes out and needs to build women up by
tearing men down you're doing something
wrong if you need to tell every guy hey
by the way even though you treat women
well even though you if that guy is good
to his girlfriend it's good to his mom
has great relationship with her sister
interacts with women in the professional
setting it's very respectful you need
him to feel less than you need him to
feel like there's some sort of closet
badness to him misogyny like he like at
his core maybe he's not that different
from someone who would rape someone you
need that because you feel insecure in
some way because you have to blame the
patriarchy maybe you had a bad
experience with a guy i don't know what
it is but you're not entitled to do that
to men if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]